[Music]
today we're gonna talk about something
very important life or death here well
at least if you look at the shelves at
your local grocery store you think it's
like with that talking about hand
sanitizers can't buy it can't buy it
anywhere these days so if you're in the
lab we're gonna show you how to make it
whose style World Health Organization
style so this is their recipe we're
gonna go through it and we're gonna show
you how to make it before we begin let's
make sure we have everything we need so
you're gonna need isopropanol 99% or
above would be good glycerin you don't
have glycerin sometimes aloe vera gel
would be alright to a hydrogen peroxide
of course water you'll need some water
for dilution we're using a centrifuge
tube here mainly for measuring and also
a graduated cylinder our master
container to hold everything I'm using a
bottle with the GLA be wide mouth so
it's easy to pour in lastly yes a spray
bottle and a funnel and a funnel gonna
meet this guy too let's go ahead and get
started the first thing we want to do is
we want to measure out about 240 mils of
IPA and then we're gonna add about 15
mils or 14 mils of hydrogen peroxide I
have a 15 mil section of each tube so
I'm just gonna kind of pour it all the
way close to the top all right so that's
weighed out and so let's put the
isopropanol in alright so now we got the
hydrogen peroxide I'm gonna put the
hydrogen peroxide in and then we're
gonna need about 5 mils of glycerine and
these are all pretty rough numbers it
doesn't have to be super exact it's just
hand sanitizer and lastly you're gonna
need about 60 mils of water
that's about good and then 60 mils of
water boom
all right there you go now let's cap
this baby and then let's shake that okay
this should be pretty good
and then lastly we're gonna get our
little spray bottle here spray bottle on
and then we're gonna label it properly
and then there you go all right very
nice